what nasa is saying because of the ridge
that goes around it they thought it that
actually came together from two
distinct parts which was the splitting
of the moon and we know their history
were eyewitness
witnesses to the account they saw the
moon split oh these are opponents of
islam
they're trying to crush islam and
they're also reporting that they saw the
splitting
of the moon people that don't know each
other people that wouldn't be able to
make up some kind of a joke or
conspiracy or lie
in the end you'd have to say you know
what it's all documented all of these
all of these details are documented wow
this is amazing
opponents who were not even in mecca but
were in the same geographical location
in the arabian peninsula
they also confirmed that yes we saw
the spreading of the moon muslims you
want to make sure we are talking about
something you can verify
research depend on we want to be honest
and academic
so in the history of this king who saw
the splitting of the moon
and became a muslim and built this
mosque they're more accurate there's
more of a science behind it than the
reports that you have for let's say
abraham lincoln george washington and
some of the
presidents what would you say to that i
can say that without the shadow of a
doubt
wow this is amazing i mean it should be
on every uh major
uh news reporting agency
was it with the bloods or the crips
a different time in life huh yeah a
different time different world
subhanallah wrote
that's one of the miracles that also is
just
amazing to see people like yourself and
many others who make that transition
going down one way of life and then now
we're here talking about
a very important topic purpose of life
why we're here you know in this world
and now this is what you specialize in
amongst other things
and what we wanted to specifically talk
about
was the miracle of the quran because we
know that
every messenger that god almighty allah
sent he
came with miracles just to give an
example jesus
moses came with miracles that were
relevant for his time but you can't
bring those back today
same thing with jesus peace be upon him
he had miracles that he did to prove
that he was indeed a messenger of allah
not a literal son of god or
divine in any nature and he did miracles
at that time but you can't bring those
back today
but we have a living miracle and you
talked about one of the specific signs
in there
which was the splitting of the moon and
then you went above and beyond and you
actually verifying them you called the
british institute can you
go ahead and uh talk to us about the
splitting of the moon this specific
miracle
and then what you actually did to
confirm it excellent
so alhamdulillah
we always want to start by praising uh
our creator
i'm talking about the the essence of
what we as muslims first believe in and
we believe in this miracle because we
know
in surat al-qamr which is a chapter in
the quran
allah tells us about that the time of
the day of judgment is
drawing closer and the moon has split
when i was studying the quran when i saw
this verse in the quran
and i looked at the reports about this
incident i found that in our history
books in islamic history books we talk
about this amazing incident
that the people the people who were the
people of quraish the people
who were politius they asked the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
for a miracle and he asked them if i
show you a miracle will you believe they
said yes
so he he asked allah he didn't do it on
his own he asked the creator
and the creator as a miraculous sign
split the moon in two
and it was a clear split where they
could see it between the mountain
and then they came back together so when
i saw this
i started to speak to some people at my
work about it even though i'm an imam
and a mosque here i do the tawa i do
that only for the sake of allah i don't
take any money from that
i work as a regulatory and quality
consultant at a medical device company
most of the people i work with i mean
well
i mean our scientists our engineers our
phds people who work
on developing new devices people who
work on
releasing new uh pharmaceuticals and so
on
so a lot of them yeah they thought when
i spoke to them about islam they always
get
surprised that somebody who's working
the medical device industry and
works with this believes in such a thing
so i was telling one of my co-workers a
phd
very intelligent man about this this
thing in the quran and he told me this
impossible scientifically it's
impossible
there is no way something as large as
the moon could could come apart and come
back together
or even two bodies like that could come
back together and would be seamless
today
so you know me and him start having this
conversation and
one day he came back to me and he said
you know i was at a presentation
and you know again he's a phd researcher
a very intelligent man he said i was at
a
at a presentation from nasa and they
were talking about one of the moons of
saturn
and this moon and it's called lipidus is
actually
what nasa is saying because of the ridge
that goes around it
they thought it that actually came
together for two distinct parts
and today together as one moon so i
thought that was interesting
and i started to research this from a
purely scientific perspective that is it
scientifically possible that two large
bodies
like a split moon could come back
together and be one body again
and i found multiple examples now i want
to be very explicit that these
these are theories that nasa has put
forward you can look that up on their
website
they have the pictures that i used in my
video and you are
feel free to share them here are all
from nasa they're not doctor
they're not photoshopped they're not our
images these are nasa images
so nasa sent a rover out the cassini
to saturn and and went and looked at the
different moons and one of the moons
that really stood out was lapidus
and lepidus has this strange ridge right
across the whole moon
and they have other features that were
different the two sides of the moon very
different
so many theories came out we don't have
any picture evidence we don't have any
eye witnesses we don't have any
video we don't have a youtube clip on
what happened
originally but the idea came out to be
from nasa
that millions of years or hundreds of
thousands of years or however long ago
either the moon split and came back
together
or two moons crashed together but today
according to nasa according to
scientific research this is
one moon that was two parts at one time
so i thought that was interesting and my
non-muslim atheist
co-worker found it very interesting
because we had talked about this and he
said you know what you were right
it is possible so we started to research
this more we found the same thing with
miranda one of the
one of the moons of your name uranus so
i thought that was interesting as well
but that's not our moon right so we got
in this discussion said well that's true
it is possible but not our moon right so
me and him started researching together
and we found
that our moon actually has two very
distinct faces
the face that's facing the earth and the
face that's facing away from the earth
and there are what's called riemann
rhema's um as you can share pictures
uh they are they are cracks or lines
that go
all across the moon in different
patterns some of them like the
like they are about 300 kilometers some
are bigger some are smaller
and nasa and scientists have always been
very curious
as as what causes these and there are
many theories
you know they're they're lava pits their
their their tunnels that have come their
the the face of the moon is actually
moving and
and the moon is extracting and so on
but all of those are theories one of the
theories that we found
that nasa had put forward was that and
it is very possible
that the moon had actually come together
from two distinct parts
and there's a rendering that nasa
created and this is a painting because
obviously we didn't have any actual
pictures
they claim it to be about you know a
billion something years ago
so they said okay two parts came
together
and made the moon as it is today oh so
that was interesting that's our moon
that we're talking about
so i started to get into this
conversation i i spoke to people who are
scientists people who
who are working on on rovers and things
and they said you know what how did the
moon even even come to exist
they said well there was a a another
moon or a planet that's the size
of mars that's crashed into the earth
and and morphed off into making the moon
as it is
such a well where's the witnesses for
that who saw this where's the video
where's the evidence
is there a big crater on the sides of
the earth they said no no
but they said we look at the moon and we
look at certain characteristics
and we deduce from it i said okay so you
have no actual
eyewitness witness you don't have any
evidence
but we're deducing okay when we look at
the moon and we look at these remus and
we look at the two very distinct sides
how do we know how did the moon come
back together or was it split or was it
two different parts they said well we
don't know so i said okay
could it be possible then that the moon
did split at one time and come back
together like the other moons that we've
seen
and they said well it is possible okay
but where's the evidence
and that's where we started to get into
the research of the evidence
islamically i presented evidence
which is from the quran first off now as
a muslim we believe in the quran that
that's
for us but as an atheist as a non-muslim
that was not convincing for them
not a problem i said okay what type of
evidence would you accept we said well i
mean do we have any eyewitness
evidence because right now we do have
cracks we do have reamers we do have all
of these
signs but do we have any eyewitness
evidence
yes we do and that's where we go to the
first aspect of the evidence that we
look at
in islam we have a science called hadith
the checking of narrations and it is
very important
for people to understand the science
because we who work on clinical trials
we who work on scientific research
we have certain standards if we can show
something to have repeatability
we can show a lot of people to have seen
the same thing then we say okay this is
acceptable
and then we research on why so here
in the lifetime of the prophet peace be
upon him we have
reports these are what we call hadith
and these are not
fairy tales these are people who are
eyewitnesses that we can tell you who
they were
who they reported it to how was their
moral character what we call
adam how was their precision and
reporting
which we called up this is more
than any other historic research that we
find out there
so now we have going from a scientist
that you are a colleague
who now is saying no this is not
possible to having a shift of opinion
it's possible
and now nasa coming forward we're
showing some kind of what seems to be
cracks
in the earth somehow coming together
what did you call them what's the term
you used
rima rima yeah rima
is meaning a trench or a line and these
are all across the moon
they're different so this would kind of
just um signify that now this could be
what the crown's talking about like the
the split right coming together so now
you're going into the second phase
eyewitnesses exactly so so the remus and
and the signs that we see
the two distinct faces of the moon show
that there are two different bodies that
did come together but
now how did it happen when did it happen
nasa doesn't have an answer for that
right they have theory but they have no
answer because they have no witnesses
they have no video they have no
satellite image they have none
but we as muslims do right so we present
our evidence of eyewitness accounts now
right okay so now because obviously
there had to have people that seen it if
you see a moon splitting you have
obviously i gotta have i gotta have
people but but here's the thing
how do we know that okay this this is uh
are there also people who are not
muslims reporting this
at the same time so so let's get there
right so let's get to the eyewitnesses
right now
so we have first and foremost um
he was a a companion of the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him he reported
this event and before we talk about
muslims and non-muslims different one
understand
that we have the biographies of all
these people
we know exactly who they were we know
when they were raised
from the people of madina the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him was in mecca
so he's one of the people that reports
this right we also have abdullah
abbas was very young at the time
abdullah we also have
now this is very important because
at the time that this event took place
he was not a muslim he was a non-muslim
he became muslim of the tree of hadith
so he's one of the people that reported
it abdullah ibn mishrod from the people
of mecca he reports he says
that the people of makkah they came to
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
and they told him if you're a prophet
show us a miracle but the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him and one of
the narrations told him what do you want
he said split the moon for us
so he prayed and these people who we can
name and we know their history were
eyewitness witnesses to the account
they saw the moon split and decide then
come back together in the same night now
again that's that's a miracle
that's an amazing event but who were the
people that reported it
well we mentioned those that were from
the companions of the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
like abdullah ibrahimos
these were the companions these were
people that we know
we know their biographies we know that
they all report at the same time in
mecca
but there wasn't just in one city there
was ana sabrina malik as we mentioned
that was in madinah
but what's more interesting in the book
with neha you will find
a narration and i looked at the
narration and it's authentic it's been
checked
there was
a benevole
these were polytheists these were the
enemies of the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him these were
these are just like okay you mentioned a
name and now this is some person like
you know because
let's say you have other books that uh
let's just compare it you know for
for instance like the bib the bible you
have certain books this is not the
disparage on anybody's faith or any but
this is what you know uh
uh bible scholars tell us you know that
we
have books in there that you cannot link
to who the authors were you know you
might have a name
but we don't know who these people are
now in contrast
how does that play out here do we
actually these people
detailed you know uh life
biography of these people perfect great
question so now
if we look at the biblical books like
matthew mark luke
john these are written according to
their account they're actually not
written by them as we see in peter
many of them there were aramaic speaking
fishermen who were illiterate
these were in coney grief they weren't
written even in the language that they
spoke
and we don't even know much about other
than maybe the location that they were
from we don't know their last time we
don't know their father's name we don't
know their wives we don't know their
children
we don't even know what kind of
precision they had in memory any of that
right
even if you leave religious text out of
it let's talk about
secular science or history that we
depend upon
eddie for example how did hitler die
we don't really know to be honest with
you you know because
who who reported what he did at the time
of death who did they tell it to right
who was alexander the great who actually
saw alexander great
that can we name like today if you i'll
give you an easier example we're in
america both of us right
now we know there to be a man named
george washington
right eddie you believe that i believe
that right there was a man named george
washington
he gave the gettysburg address right
who's who heard it from him can we name
anybody i i've gone to historians and
i've told them okay
give me the first hand report give me
who was the one standing
there that heard it and who did they
tell it to
until it was written down in a book in
history
we just believe it because in a history
book but no we're going to a
whole different level of precision we're
saying i'll give
for example i said abdullah abbas his
name is abdullah his father's name is
abbas
he was the uncle of the prophet
salallahu he was from the tribe of
quraysh
we know his sons we know his wife we
know where he lived where you know where
he moved
we know how many hadith he memorized the
number exactly
we know this is all documented all of
these all of these details are
documented wow this is amazing
and you see these books behind me i have
a whole
section in my library that is just
dedicated to the biographies of these
people we have entire
volumes written on each one of them up
to the point that we even know what kind
of food they like
we know what kind of business they were
in we know how long they live which
cities they went to
all of this not just this we know how
good they were at memorizing and
reporting correctly
now if this was just one report that
would be amazing but no
we have what we call muttawater these
are technical terms
i want to explain them to the audience
especially to the non-muslim audience to
understand
the precision that goes into recording
hadith
right it's called what does that mean it
comes through
numerous chains it's not just one person
who witnessed it
right so as i'm and i'm telling you this
right now
all of these people that we have reports
from regarding this
incident right not just muslim but
non-muslims that were there in mecca
now all of these different people who
some of them
that were like in medina they saw this
event
at the same time so it's not like one or
two or three people
now if it was only those people that
were
muslim those people that were pro
the message of islam then somebody could
say you know what they're all making it
up
okay but now we have walid an enemy of
the prophet sallam who
fought the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him we have
abuja the famous
dave we have uh us
we have uh
report that we saw this so these are
these are oppo now these are opponents
of islam
they're they're trying to crush islam
and they're also reporting that they saw
the splitting of the moon that's
mentioned in the quran
yes not just that when they saw this
they were amazed but they were people
who had a lot of hatred for the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him so they said
you know what
this was magic he tricked us right
so what they did and these are historic
reports in hadith books that i checked
and in my video
i present all the references for anybody
who wants to recheck them
now what they did is they went out
and they asked the other the trade
people the people caravans the
people who were polytheist enemies of
prophet sallam
who were out of makkah at that time they
said you know what if the prophet
muhammad tricked us and they did he did
this magic on us
he can't do it on everybody so we're
going to ask those people that weren't
in mecca at the time
when their caravans came back and he
said hey we saw this this event did you
guys see this
they confirmed those enemies opponents
who were not even in mecca but were in
the same geographical location in the
arabian peninsula
they also confirmed that yes we saw
the spreading of the moon so now you
have extraordinary evidence you have
the companions the prophet muhammad many
of them
numerous reports and now what is very
important is each one of them they told
different people
and who told different people through
all these different chains of narrations
and is recorded across different
historic record records
the books of hadith all of them report
this
this takes it to what we call muttawater
to such numerous chains
that numeric numerically it's impossible
that this didn't happen
give an example like uh like you know
trump is walking his dog
you know you gave this example uh go
ahead and share that
you can really hit home so let's talk
about that right today
if somebody uh let's let's give you two
examples one like a very personal
example eddie for example
you got a neighbor that tells you you
know what uh
don't go down that street the police has
blocked it off
right somebody tell one neighbor tells
you that well
i mean i don't know how well you know
your neighbor and i don't know how
maybe he's maybe he's got you know some
issues maybe he's just kind of making
that up maybe he doesn't want you to go
down that street
so you might be like you know that might
be true it might not be true but if that
neighbor tells you and your other
neighbor tells you
and some dude coming down the street
said hey you know what the police has
blocked it off
now when you have three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen four
if you have so many different people
they come and tell you eddie the streets
blocked off
people that don't know each other people
that wouldn't be able to make up some
kind of a joke or conspiracy or lie
in the end you'd have to say you know
what the police probably blocked off
that street because
so many people are not going to come
together and that don't know each other
for no apparent reason
and make up a lie and if some of those
neighbors hate each other some are trump
supporters some are biden supporters
and they both come and tell you that
that street's blocked off
you know what street's blocked off right
this is how we check
references in the scientific industry
when we look at
a clinical trial if we repeat use of
certain drug or a vaccine
and we see an effect repeatedly we say
you know what if the effect is from the
drug
so when you have different people from
different tribes
from different cities who have different
motives some are enemies
some are friends some are proponents
some are opponents
all come and report that we saw them
then we say you know what this this is a
fact this has to have happened
because all these peop different people
from different backgrounds
who didn't come together and discuss
this issue
he reported this years later he was in
madina he wasn't even in mecca at the
time
years later go ahead go ahead go ahead
finish your time
one of the people who reported this at
that time
he was not a muslim he was he was an
enemy later
from from this event and other things he
became a muslim and then he still
reported he said you know i remember
at that time even though i wasn't a
muslim i remember seeing this
now i'll tell you eddie the very very
very important point
and this is where you really gotta be
amazed
this was in mecca this incident happened
and it was revealed in the quran
as me and you both know in surat if
somebody wants to look it up
in the first right you have this event
now the prophet muhammad he migrated to
madinah
and he was in madina and then he came
back this whole time
all these polytheists who were enemies
of islam
who were trying to make up all kinds of
rumors against the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
they heard this verse they never
challenged it
think about this if this hadn't happened
those people were politics would have
said you know what the quran says the
moon split
but we were in mecca we didn't see it
very profound point right now
what you're saying is that very
important a lot of times people skip
over these you know just really uh
in your face uh points and signs but
it's really nice how you uh highlighted
this so they would have definitely
challenged because obviously this is a
bold statement
the moon is split imagine but nobody
challenged it imagine in our time
if president trump comes back and says
you know what
i sent a a a a space mission
to jupiter right it makes a claim like
that right
by this administration and everybody
would jump on that they would jump on
that what
you made this claim show us where is the
video for what is your
evidence who are you witnesses bring
nasa bring this this never happened
they would challenge it if biden made
that claim trump would challenge it
right see you see you have opponents so
if they can catch you in something like
this
they will jump on it the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
he split the moon the quran had the
people who were the enemies of islam
would hear these verses all the time
right me and you when we pray in ramadan
is coming up
we hear the whole quran we hear these
verses me and you when we read the quran
even
even an opponent of islam today who goes
and gets the quran
he reads these verses so imagine those
people that were physically in battles
against the prophet peace be upon him
they were in these propaganda battles
they heard these verses they heard these
claims from the companions of the
prophet peace be upon him
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
said it they could have chat they said
you know what
we didn't see this but all of them
admitted every report that we have
everything
those that we don't have reports we
don't know but those that we have
reported in history all of them admitted
yes this incident took place
what if you go outside of this
geographical location
are there are there people that now saw
it outside of
you said mecca medina but how about out
of the arabian peninsula so this took me
to my next
uh stage of research right so
this was amazing for me from a
scientific perspective and then from a
historic perspective looking at this
but i i got a lot of questions from my
co-workers think that i would discuss
this with
that well if something amazing like this
had happened
what about people in other geographical
locations did they
see the moon splitting of the moon so i
started to research this issue now
and you have to understand that we're
looking at uh
more than 1400 years ago so we didn't
have cameras we didn't have this kind of
technology
what we had were people that would write
down in their different historic work
so i started to research different
history books from different regions of
the world
to see if something like this would
report was reported we have things like
uh that are ambiguous and i didn't want
to depend on anything like this
i want to depend on what is verifiable
what's research what's authentic right
so i found that the mayans for example
they had in their calendar a split moon
an image of a split moon coming together
but i can't depend on that because
that's not clearly stating
that this happened at that time and in
that place and how it happened that's
something ambiguous
we have the the chinese who have a moon
cake that's split and used but i don't
depend on any of that
i mean those can be like you can add
those in kind of
they're kind of weak but it's still
somewhat of you know
uh you really want to be academically
sound
you don't want things like that people
could just like no sir nostradamus type
of you know uh predictions
you hit you hit it on the head right
there right so we don't want to we don't
like we see a lot of christians and jews
and things sometimes they bring very
ambiguous things in
and and we don't want to be like that as
muslims we want to make sure we are
talking about something you can verify
research depend on
we want to be honest and academic so i
started to look in
my research here in the works of hadith
first and foremost right
looking at the different reports that
were from mecca from madina from the
tribes from caravans
from enemies from proponents i
researched this where it was a hundred
percent verifiable because i could find
the names of the enemies even and the
proponents and opponents and those that
became muslim those that never became
muslim but still admitted that this
miracle had taken place
so that was the crux of why i believed
in it but i wanted to see if there's any
supporting evidences
even looking at those types of evidences
that were ambiguous
i didn't accept those i started to first
look at what would be the time frame and
who would be able to see it
right because for example euro i believe
in new york right
chicago chicago close enough i'm just
kidding um so
i'm i'm on the west coast i'm in san
diego right so our
time zones are different but if you look
at somebody in england right now or in
china right now
where there's night and day we're not
seeing the same things
so if somebody somebody's looking at the
moon in the early part of the night
well they're going to be people that are
not going to be able to see the moon
because it's going to be daytime it's
going to be bright sun out you know and
sometimes you can see the moon in the
daytime but regularly you cannot
right that this is not possible some
people are going to be fast asleep
because it's going to be 3 a.m or 2 a.m
or close to 5 a.m or whatever
a part of the night that usually
especially at that time people weren't
out looking at the sky
so i had to start looking at where would
it be possible so no doubt in the
arabian
peninsula around that geographical
location it would be possible and we
have reports
from different cities and different
places we got that
if you look at the americas and if you
look at
europe most likely at this time of the
night it would be daytime here
because as we see the sun starts it
cycles rising from the east and going
towards the west
so when it when night has come to the
arabian peninsula because the moon was
visible
it would have been daytime in the
americas so most likely you will not see
a report out of there
if you look at very far to the east it's
going to be the
depth of the night it's going to be
almost you know getting close to the
morning so
this is the time especially at that time
and agricultural society everybody's
going to be asleep
so the only areas that we saw that would
be close to the oregon peninsula that
was going to be
directly east and that is the area today
of
india and the subcontinent and the
central asia area here
so i started to research is there any
report out of those areas that would
support
this clear evidence that we already have
and i found
a reference of a book um
that was written by one of the muslim
scholars in one of his books i looked at
that so that i started to research where
the manuscript was
and i found it to be in london so i
emailed the british library
and i got a report back and in my video
i read the whole email i'll just read a
part of what they
wrote which is from the asian africa
reference services in the india office
in asia africa study inquiries and they
have a subsection which is the india
office papers oriental language
publication or into language manuscripts
so i asked them is there any such
manuscript so they confirm
that there is a manuscript reference io
islamic
a two eight zero seven and on portfolios
81 through 104 there is an account of an
indian king who is a hindu king
from kerala from the south of india and
he
witnessed this and then later when he
went met muslims
he accepted islam now
this was a book called
now this is something that we cannot
verify
to the standard that we have in hadith
because we don't have first person we
don't know a lot of the history because
the indian history was not
written down the same way there was not
that verification that we have in hadith
but it does exist
right so i thought let me look into it
i'm not depending on it as an evidence
because
go ahead so now you're taking it to
another level now you have someone
pretty much who can see daytime events
nighttime events
okay in a different part of geographical
location and this was
in india now in india in the southern
part of india yes
and this is a king from india his name
was again so we'll get to his name
this is uh uh this is the first step
that i had in my research so i said okay
i found this now i as an academic i i
didn't
believe this was verified enough for me
to depend on and i'm already depending
on the clear narration from hadith
but this is another source that i wanted
to dig into now
i don't have carbon dating for this we
don't have verification in that way
so i emailed the national library of
india and this is
a uh a segment that they have which is
the national digital library project of
india
where they have the national library and
they've digitized a lot of their
manuscripts
and under their central library and i
found out about them that they're even
iso certified it's a very
well set up uh library in it and i i got
to
a institute of technology uh part of it
and i emailed them and asked them do you
have this manuscript
so they wrote me an email back and they
said we don't have this manuscript this
manuscript's actually in london
we have a digital copy but they told me
that there is actually an israeli
orientalist uh dr yo johannen uh fredman
who translated it so i thought that's
interesting that people have even
translated so i got the translation and
i found some interesting things
that mentioned this but there were some
things that didn't make sense so i said
are there any other reports about this
so they told me there are new and this
is their words this is not my words
so i'm quoting from their email they
said there are numerous
oral and written traditions that state
that
chairman purumal the chera king
called shanakra who had the title
chairman promote is a title that their
kings would have who ruled from
621 to 640. now again
it's very important because this is a
hindu
from india this is not a muslim who is
telling us
that according to their standards not
our standards their standards
this is a oral and written tradition
that they have accepted
and the time frame that they put him in
matches exactly
where the the life of the prophet saws
in the later part here
so he said who ruled from 621 to 640
witnessed the splitting of the moon and
when he met muslim traders converted to
islam in 627
a.d now now this is coming from the
national
library of india and he gave me
additional references now this is very
important
there is a book called islam
and he says this is the earliest
manuscript on the genesis of islam in
kerala
housed in the digital library and he
gave me the reference number and
another book that is confirmed by dr
harriman now these two works that we
just mentioned were written by muslims
but there was a confirmation by and
according to them
uh dr hermann gundrat a german
christian missionary scholar and
linguist
of this manuscript there is a portuguese
writer
dorte barbosa he writes about this
mighty king as well
who ruled in kerala converted to islam
and ordered the building of the chairman
mosque and this is very important eddie
make sure we get back to this mosque
in a minute and he ordered this building
in
629 a.d another portuguese writer these
are all non-muslim
historians named jose barbaros and a and
a supporting
separate portuguese author named diegos
carcortes because the portuguese had
ruled goa in this part of india
they had looked at a lot of these
manuscripts they also confirmed
through oral and written tradition that
it was well known history
that an indian king had in fact seen the
splitting of the moon
and had in fact converted to islam from
this miracle when he had met muslims
and as a historic evidence this mosque
still stands this is the end i'm just
giving you some highlights in my
in my video i actually read the entire
email but these are
very important aspects to understand we
as muslims don't depend on any of these
reports because we cannot verify them
to our standards and there are some
discrepancies between these reports but
according to the indian national
institute of library here their project
there are multiple reports not one
multiple history books
that they have manuscripts of that were
verified
by christian missionaries in different
western academics
that came and said no doubt in southern
india then which is kerala today
in that area there are oral and written
traditions
who mentioned an indian king who saw the
spirit of the moon
and converted to islam from seeing the
splitting of the moon
and he ordered a mosque to be built
what's very interesting eddie
is that mosque is still standing till
today we have it it's been renovated
obviously but it's still standing
and if you india is it in again in
southern india and kerala malamar kerala
the southern india part
now what i found to be amazing you know
because none of this can be verified to
our standard we don't have carbon we
don't have
uh reports of who witnessing things but
this is indian history and in that time
frame
fourteen hundred years ago this is the
way indian history is recorded through
oral
and such later written traditions but
this is so well accepted i contacted a
good friend of mine he's a phd he's a
professor
and you know he is from southern india
and he said you know when we were kids
we were taught this in school this is
well known to us this is
accepted history in fact he pointed me
something very interesting the prime
minister of india
who as many people know is very
um nationalistic hardcore right
hindu nationalist rss bjp anti-muslim
party
so he's not somebody who was going to be
easy on muslims or in muslim history
there's somebody who were very
nationalistic hindu
even he tweeted about this
about this splitting of the moon and
about and he had a golden replica
of this mosque built repeat that the
prime minister of india
yes is sen is doing what again he's
actually this his this hit this history
now he's actually
because it's part of their history
exactly now when we see the prime
minister india it's also very important
to understand
he is from the bjp party meaning this is
the anti-muslim party he is the one that
enacted laws to try to you know
take kashmir and and have hardship on
the muslims there and
and all kinds of things were so
politically
he is very much against muslims right
but even him he admits to this history
and he had a golden replica made
of this mosque that was built by this
king
and he gave that as a gift to the king
of saudi arabia
to try to promote trade relations and he
and he tweeted and i've given pictures
of those tweets and you can look it up
you can if you look at me you have all
these pictures where can people go to
see all this what you're talking about
we have uh what's called the one message
foundation which is a dao
organization here and on the youtube
channel if you put in youtube one
message foundation the channel will come
up
if you look at the videos i have a video
on this and in it i give all of the
pictures i give the pictures of the moon
the fades of the moon the satellite
images from nasa the historic
pictures from the books of history that
we verified as muslims
in the hadith books from the from the
proponents and opponents
and also i read the emails exactly i i'm
not verifying these reports
these books because i'm not there in
those libraries but this is from them
that their verification i read them and
i show a picture
of the actual mosque that is still
standing we show a picture what it
looked like
and a picture of the golden replica
that was made by the prime minister of
india
the bjp prime minister of india to give
us a gift
and i have pictures of the tweets that
he sent out talking about this mosque
and the history
of muslim interactions and the history
of this king
who saw the splitting of the moon and
became a muslim
and built this mosque and he the prime
minister of india today
accepts this as their history and used
this
as a part of their trade negotiation
with saudi arabia so now that's a very
important thing to understand
that we in the west may not realize this
but the people of india especially in
southern india
they know this they have oral traditions
they have written traditions they have
accepted it according to their standards
of history the prime minister of india
who even though with his
animosity toward islam even he accepts
it and tweets about it
so this is something amazing so what
have the
opponents of islam because even if you
leave a little bit of room you know
for uh for them to attack they will
so what do they say what's the counter
to this and so we have
we have counters that we get all the
time so we get counters like for example
some of these historic reports
they say well you know there are certain
contradictions in them certain
date ranges that don't make certain
events that they report that some of
them mentioned for example him going
to the prophet muhammad peace be upon
accepting islam at the hand of the
prophet muhammad some of them
sallallahu some of them saying that he
became muslim later with malik
some of them and that is all true we
totally agree because these
are according to their oral and written
traditions
they don't meet the standards that we
have right but if you look at the chera
kings and these were
the kings who ruled southern india all
of their accepted history today
100 of their accepted history today from
that time period and before
is recorded in the same one and this is
very important
because i started to research other
events that happened
nothing to do with islam in southern
india at that time well they're the same
way they have oral reports they have
written reports later
by the portuguese by the dutch by
muslims by others
and those reports also have certain
contradictions but that's how they
record their history
now us as muslims we have a different
level of verification
for example there is a narration in a
book that i have here
in in the muslim where it mentions this
indian king in an islamic history book
sending gifts to the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him but i didn't use that
report why
because there is a slight weakness in
the chain and some of the reports
they said that this was actually the
king of rome so when i find anything
minor even like that i leave it aside
there is a report in an ali about a king
of india
becoming muslim but i didn't accept
those because there was weakness in the
chains
we as muslims stick to only what is
authentically verified and acceptable
so this is very important and they even
our
opponents have no response to this i
have challenged people i go out
every sunday to the park here we give
dawah as you can see the videos
we call people toward islam we challenge
we have people come we mention this
they cannot challenge the islamic
reports the ones that we are depending
upon
now these other reports that are from
india
there are inconsistencies in them yes
that is true because that is how their
history is somebody gave a report
somebody gave a date range but if you
look at the the different reports in the
different books
oro and written no doubt it is a part of
their history
right so the opponents have no answer
for that
they're more accurate there's more of a
science behind it than the reports that
you have for let's say
abraham lincoln george washington and
some of the
presidents what did you say to that i
can say that without the shadow of a
doubt without any hesitation
as somebody who has studied how history
is preserved in the western
world and how the science my master's
degree i have two masters one is
executive mba my second masters is in
this science of hadith
this science about reporting about the
last prophet muhammad peace be upon him
now let me ask you this we have uh
abraham lincoln for example you brought
up
an excellent example we know that he was
shot
uh you know in a theater okay
other than the one who shot him who
didn't report it who witnessed it oh you
can say maybe his wife
witnessed it we maybe other people there
okay who did they tell it to
they didn't go and write a book about it
themselves who did they tell this report
to and how good was their memory how
good was their precision
what kind of moral character did they
have who were there
when we look at other people around not
just the people that were involved but
the people who reported this historical
incident
we start to lose credibility because we
don't know
george washington many historic events
that we talk about
some of the greatest speeches that we
record from certain
historic figures in history classes in
my university in the in the
in san diego i'm talking about they were
challenged and many of them
really didn't have eyewitness accounts
they were written off
writings of people much later on unlike
the islamic verification when we talk
about a hadith
a incident that happened in the time of
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
we can tell you who the eyewitnesses
were we will tell you how many there
were
we will tell you their history we will
tell you who did they report it to
not just okay the the people who saw it
and then a history book written a
thousand years later no
the islamic history the science of
hadith is so precise
and sometimes we have 70 different
people who told 70 different people
who told 70 different people who was
documented in different
areas different lands different tribes
some in baghdad some in kufa
some in debash so all of this
when it comes sometimes exact same
wording
there is no doubt to this you cannot
scientifically it's verifiable
wow this is amazing i mean it should be
on every uh major
uh news reporting agency i mean people
should um
really take this to the next level and
make a documentary actually of this
and what are what are the and this is
what we put out there for you know
you know people who are just uh looking
for truth you know to
compile all this evidence i don't think
there's ever been like a major
documentary on something like this have
you seen anything
i have not and i think me and you should
work on a project i'm ready if you're
ready
this is yeah we should get some
filmmakers you know people who really
we get contacted all the time you know
people who want to contribute i mean
this is a great way we can put them in
touch with you
so if you're out there listening to this
this is amazing can you imagine
tell me this well you're going through
this and verifying this you know
how did the does this for yourself
personally is this iman booster
of course you know my my iman
first and foremost when i read it in the
quran i already believed in it because i
know about the other miracle the quran i
know about the scientific miracles
linguistic miracles
for me as a muslim this was something
that
i believed in as it was but when i
started reading the hadith and not just
one hadith but looking at how many
hadith there were looking at the fact
that
also in his tafsir he said this is
mother
it showed to me that this is through
numerous chains
and and it built a love that i had for
the prophet muhammed peace be upon him
but it grew that love because i imagined
you know
that allah gave him such an honor and
then i started to think about
you know the the other reports that came
out of different parts of the world
and i started to discuss this with my
co-workers i tried to give them dawah
with this right
even my atheist co-workers said you know
what this is the most amazing thing
that i have ever heard about islam he
says you know i've heard about islam
many
things and i you know he made a really
good point and i'm going to make this
point here eddie
uh as muslims we believe in the prophet
moses and prophet jesus because of islam
but
if you want to look at it from his
perspective as an atheist
my co-worker is an atheist he said you
have given me more evidence
about the splitting of the moon and this
miracle of the prophet that i cannot
deny
than any christian has given me about
any miracle of the prophet
jesus or any jew has given me about any
miracle of the prophet moses
now that's very interesting right from
an atheist perspective not
for me as a muslim i have my own belief
but from his perspective he said
that jews tell us and christians tell us
and the muslims tell us that moses split
the ocean
well where's the evidence for that other
than biblical reports which again
you know if you look at the old
testament jewish writings you look at
the torah it is not firsthand reports
anymore because of the loss of the
actual manuscript and the rewritings
that were done
the new testament for example again not
firsthand reports so
where are the first-hand historic
reports is there any sign of it today
that we can find
no right it's just belief if you talk
about
miracles of jesus these reports if you
look in the new testament
are all written by not firsthand
witnesses these are written 70 years 100
years
40 years after the time of jesus and the
language the jesus didn't speak
they've been they've been they say the
gospel according to matthew but not
written by matthew
right according to mark not run by mark
any dr bart ehrman or any
researcher will tell you that these were
not written by actual apostles so
so now i think about this many
christians will take these
on blind faith but we as muslims can
give you evidence
we can give you eyewitness reports even
that atheist
asked me for a quran after that he asked
me for quran
and i want our viewers who are not
muslim that are viewing this
i have i have one request after
listening to all this
go go get a quran just get a quran get a
book of the biography of the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
and just learn about it learn about
these things
ask us questions email eddie ask or send
a message ask
at least you owe it to yourself to learn
about this
we got about five minutes left i wanted
to ask you a couple more questions what
does this entail so this king
who was from a hindu background is that
correct yes so then
he went and accepted islam people are
listening to this and they're like wow
this is amazing if this
truly is now they go research and they
say like wow this is you know
this is the this is this is uh sound you
know this is
a deed a miracle along with all the
other miracles i mean the quran is a
living miracle anybody put us under the
test i mean they can see that this is
not something that
could come from muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he was just the
last and final messenger
and then the simple message that's in
the the quran can you talk about that
what did this king accept you say this
word islam and all those
others now over close to 2 billion
people who are practicing
it today islam is not a religion that
started with any one man unlike you look
at christianity named after christ
judaism after judah buddhism after
buddha shinto
and you know all these religions are
started by a certain idea or a person at
a time
islam is that true religion that that
one creator
sent to all the prophet aslam means when
you
submit your will to your creator so from
adam and moses
and abraham and jesus and muhammad peace
be upon all of them
we love all of them these are all the
prophets of that one god
and those all of those prophets when
they submitted themselves to their
creator they were muslim
that is what islam is islam is not the
religion that start after the time of
the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him islam is the same
religion
that abraham and moses and jesus taught
and they were muslims
by definition of the word and that's why
we have a sign
in our book that says jesus is a muslim
we love jesus we love moses we love
abraham we love muhammad peace be upon
all of them you will never see a muslim
disrespect any of them
you will never see us making cartoons or
or any kind of
disrespect to any of them why because
those are our prophets as well we love
them there's only one message that one
creator sent
and that is the message of islam if you
look at the first commandment the second
commandment this is the message of islam
that there is only one creator there's
only one lord one allah
one god only one and he's the only one
that should be worshipped
idols should not be worshiped that is
what this hindu king accepted is to deny
the worship of monkeys and rats and
idols and things like this
and to worship that only one creator
that created me that created you that
sent all these prophets that gave us
life
that gave us that created this world and
the universes and whatever else is out
there
the creator of all of that to worship
that one created this is the message of
islam
every one of us will live during the
time of a prophet if me and you
had he lived during the time of jesus we
would be from his followers and we would
be muslim
that's what a muslim would be we would
believe in that one god and we would
follow jesus
if we lived in the time of the prophet
moses we would be muslim by following
moses
we would believe in that one god and we
would follow the prophet moses peace be
upon him
and me and you today as we know we live
in the time of the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him he is the last of
those prophets
so for for us it is to believe in that
one god
and to follow the prophet of that time
which is the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him and him being the last prophet
he is the prophet of the day of judgment
this is islam what do you like to tell
people because
you are in a different zone at one point
point
in your life and there was one thing it
really was touching how
and it was scary at the same time but
touching how you actually
saw that as a sign and then you just
went in another direction you started to
think more but
what i want to say is you were in a
certain zone that zone like most people
are material things cars you know
uh for men women women uh you know doing
you know
the things that they do men doing the
things that they do the wants and these
the desires pretty much just following
you know the desires but then you had a
an experience uh you were supposed to be
at a phone booth at one time
and then someone else ended up at that
phone booth and that person ended up
getting killed is that correct
that puts you in a different zone so my
point my question is
how do we what do you like to tell
people to get them from the zone of just
materialism
uh following the lust and desires to
this zone of talking because now times
you know
as you start to talk about bible you
know prophets they're like excuse me
what
what
are you saying it's like you're talking
a different language
eddie what's life about why do we live
what's our goal when i was growing up i
grew up in
in what we call the barrio which you
would call the hood right we were in in
bad neighborhoods
and we looked up to drug dealers we
looked up to gang members i didn't grow
up with muslims i didn't grow up
in in a pious household and these kinds
of things
even though ethnically yes i was from
pashtun from pakistan but
but i grew up in san diego and i had no
muslim friends
all my friends you know most of them
were mexican many of them were
black or white or whatever but none of
them were arabs or anything like this so
when i grew up
we looked up to guys that had money that
had cars that had girls that had that
those material things and that's what we
worked for we joined gangs and did all
this thing
i i got involved in the gang world when
i was around 10 years of age around 12
14 i was a
bona fide gang member and growing up
when we when we had money when we
started to deal with drugs and things
like this when we got big
we started to live it up what we thought
was the life
we got low riders we got impalas we got
we got we had
girls like more than you could handle we
had money in our pocket we'd be throwing
around you know you know we started to
get a taste even though we didn't own
houses or buildings or anything because
that's not how we thought right
but but when that lifestyle came
you know it came with a price and and my
you know what i at that time considered
a very close friend you know somebody
who i grew up with somebody that
you know he was two years older than me
but we we were like brothers like
you know he was mexican but i used to be
able to you know we used to have
a a place where the gang members would
hang out and then you'd have his house
nobody's allowed to go in the house
like very strict family rules right but
i was one of those people that would go
into his house his mother knew me
you know they they would speak spanish
to me they would tell me they would
think i was mexican you know
i'm not mexican they'll be like come on
man don't be ashamed of being mexican
i'd be like no i'm from pakistan man i'm
pushed too and then they'd be like
don't worry about it you're mexican for
us so i was very close to him
so at the time you know a girl called me
and i was supposed to go meet with her
and things
and and there was a setup and and i got
busy with somebody else
and he was like hey you know i'm going
to go and take that i'm like yeah go for
it and he went there
and and he got killed and i was at his
funeral
and it was supposed to be me you know
the setup was for me but but he got
killed but
when i was at the funeral i saw them you
know he had a
hole you know 357 lines and he had and
all kinds of but they would patch you up
right i mean they'd pat you up for a
funeral
and i looked at him i looked at his body
and i realized you know he was he was
only 20 years of age at the time
i was around 17 18 he was 20. right
and he didn't look at peace he was a
lifeless body
then i looked at at the car you know we
had pitched in together at that time and
but he
he was older he used to keep we had a 64
impala nice
low rider hydraulics and somebody else
was driving his car his brother was
driving his car
he had 13 girlfriends a guy you know at
that time
and many of them they had kids from you
know when you when you're up in the gang
world
you know you get a lot of those perks
they would say right
all of those girls i saw them crying on
somebody else's shoulders
and i saw them at the funeral crying
with some other guy some other guy was
already sweeping in there right
i went to his house that day his
brothers were already fighting over his
things
that ben davis jacket this this is mine
i'm going to take this right the same
day all the
all the money he had made from drug
dealing or whatever else
somebody else had in their pocket and it
made me realize
that everything we thought to be success
cars money
girls wealth whatever respect all of
that was gone
you were going to go into a grave by
yourself just you
and whatever deeds whatever belief
whatever you did
for god or didn't that's all that's
going to go so i realized
that you can't make money and fame and
just chasing girls or
or these kinds of things the purpose of
your life you have to realize there's a
higher purpose
and you have to wake up and you have to
research and you have to read if you're
if you're a muslim you need to wake up
and go back to the quran and the sunnah
if you're not muslim you need to
research you need to find out what's the
purpose of your life
and wake up because you don't know my
friend that's dead
he didn't know he was going to die that
day he was 20 years old
so you don't know how long you have it's
time to wake up and realize that there's
a greater purpose we need to focus on
and we'll and with that advice there's a
greater purpose that we need to focus on
thank you so much for sharing that story
we're going to have to get you back to
get more details
of your journey to islam but you left
people to really you know something
fascinating
uh to really look into this miracle of
the quran and then from there
indeed we know it is a book sent down
for the guidance of all mankind what are
you going to do with that now it's up to
you thank you so much for
sharing that with us
protect us
[Music]
um